I could tell you you used to get in
trouble a lot by the way I saw you and
Bobby the way I saw you treat Bobby in
the airport when you went on the road
with him really the way you would carry
his bags although he basically rolled
out the red carpet for him and yeah I
remember that yeah you were like really
big extra like say that you're not you
know you're not in my eyes an open mic
or anything I look at you like a Fahim
Anwar like Jane a lot you someone like
Jade somebody that now is on the brink
of possibly really making it you know so
I don't really look at you that way I
mean in fact the one last time I where
did you open for me last San Jose oh no
with San Antonio yeah I literally the
last time I in my head it was
pandemonium for you I could not but I
honestly I'm gonna be real with you
rarely and I bring him I brought hard
hitters I couldn't I struggled every
show I think yeah that's how good you
were
that's how good you were I told her I
can't I was there I I was actually
worried I was like oh [ __ ] I can't
[ __ ] do it that's a big you know
theater too and that audience laughed
first tree I mean you crushed boom and
that's what I knew I went oh my god
there's this guy says is there you're
there now now all you need to do is just
get a name and then now you can headline
you know you're doing what Kim oh what
are you doing I'm doing The Late Late
Show with James Corden tomorrow tomorrow
in the day are you nervous
I know I am but not as much as I was
because I ran this set so much how does
it work do they let you do it over if
you make a mistake no I'm not sure I
don't think that's the case it's a tight
ship that they run because I do not do
that how was yours 4 to 5 listener in I
saw Regan one time on a Late Show yeah
and not do well look I think was the
Tonight Show I've seen him do great but
one time I saw him he wasn't and they
don't they that's it you have one shot
one shot yeah so it's a lot of pressure
it's a lot of pressure
but you don't achieve TV before right
you know here's Comedy Central the trick
here's the trick waiting for you this is
the trick anyone listening you're a
comic you're doing TV
the trick is regardless of how you're
doing you just in your face
pretend you're killing no because they
can edit it somehow yeah I mean
literally like if you can just convince
your face yeah yeah that you're like
killing even though you don't the
timings off or the jokes are coming out
weird right yeah you can still survive
that but if you let if you let them
affect you right and they can see the
bomb oh my god don't do that no that's
why I could never pass for looking calm
and cool because I always get the sweat
mustache uh-huh and it's just it just
shines it just reflects all this light
so on cameras just like oh that [ __ ] is
in trouble she's dying on the inside but
you're at a point where your ego won't
allow it
what do you mean because here's what
happens is is that I mean I don't hate
talking about like this but the other
day I was shooting you know the sitcom
that I'm on right and there was a couple
of lines that were that were really just
difficult the first I couldn't get it
out clean and you know they did a couple
of tags and it couldn't get it all clean
and then I could feel a little tension
and things like we gotta go come on
right yeah and I could I remembered I
could succumb to the pressure and fear
and just unravel but I said to myself
know you're gonna [ __ ] do it right
now because it's just the consequences
you don't want that right and your ego
just kind of pulls you through it I
think that you're at that level when you
go up on the quarterman have you ever
unraveled on stage like unraveled
meaning like Bobby like ran out after
two minutes and then blacked out type of
onion yeah I mean that I used to be the
case actually I was doing like a long
set you know and I I I panicked
I threw in the closer where it wasn't
and the other thing and then it was like
I literally I had this list I wrote out
my set list on my napkin yeah and I'm
like it was bad I ran behind the thing
and I grabbed it like and I came back
I'm like that's it guys and that got a
laugh I'm like at least I ended with a
laugh but it was [ __ ] terrible like I
wanted to make a 90-degree turn on the
freeway I've never done like I've done
that where like I was at post a headline
and I rearrange the jokes in a way where
I don't know what else to do you know
like I forget cuz some jokes go with
other jokes right right in chunk oh yeah
when you switch it around sometimes you
get lost in it and then you forget judge
gigantic chunks so if you're supposed to
do 45 minutes you're 20 in and you're
like I'm out
yeah I have nothing else yeah and then I
do you know the trick of like crowd play
what do you do yeah and then it doesn't
work and then you know you have no out
and you're [ __ ]
yeah me where you're [ __ ]
I did a Houston improv the first time I
headline there I did 17 minutes yeah
because I you know we're supposed to do
45 yeah I said 17 minutes I got offstage
and fans were like talking to like the
manager going you know I'm in and then
like a matter coming going on does that
all you can do right yeah I know I
rearranged it in a way in a fashion but
you don't want to hear it I don't want
to hear it because they're they're there
to sell drinks yeah so they need that 45
minutes to sell the drinks in 17 there's
drinks and Ernie man at the table yeah
Ted sonar you know I don't know
it's a nightmare and then people want
their money back it's like a [ __ ]
nightmare dude it's hard it's hard you
know you're trying to find tricks but
it's like the whole thing of like crowd
work it's like it's like almost like
Houdini with like locks like that
straitjacket with locks you're trying to
find the combination and get out of
there before you drown and sometimes you
end up drowning it's just how it goes
yeah it's it's the worst feeling and
some of these like so a lot of these
clubs now because people want people
want to see celebrities I'm not gonna
name names okay I'm not gonna name you
like I refuse to name names but there
have been clubs where they've had you
know a pretty big star who isn't a stand
of that headline because they can draw
but what they go when they go up on
stage it's a disaster so they have to
figure out ways to help this celebrity
come up with the time so they'll do like
what you do um just why don't you bring
everyone in the audience on stage and
interview them like little tricks like
that
Oh improv yeah like a hog hog everyone
in the audience they do stuff like that
to kill the guy right yeah I mean I
don't want to name names but there's
some big ones that I know that had to do
tricks up there when that happened I
would have loved to hug everyone in the
audience we're gonna take another second
to applaud our sponsors
[Music]